[Music]
they'd arrived for a Civic greeting
but this wasn't the welcome to York that
expected four eggs flung at the king
they come close but miss and the King
carefully Carries On
captured by the
way
hurling eggs and abuse the protester is
surrounded
and quickly brought down
[Music]
carried away through the rows of Royal
fans
to the fans getting thrown straight on
the floor Lewis was stood next to the
protester and saw it all
uh next
to the left and then when the king
actually got out he started throwing
eggs and everything just kind of went
apart yeah I was right Nigel was also
nearby and then all of a sudden the eggs
started coming over the top
but we never had this in that time
if the King was irked it didn't show as
he unveiled a statue honoring the queen
The Carving commissioned years ago now
pride of place outside York Minster
and here another encounter with the
crowds this time just smiles and
handshakes no more eggs but perhaps a
reminder even well meant walkabouts can
go wrong Laura bundock Sky News York